I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi. We are very excited today because today we are breaking down the fabulous. fabulous musical movie, Greece, too. I had no idea what I was in for. But before we get into it, I think I need a wardrobe change. Well, maybe I need a wardrobe change too. Oh, no. I did something. Okay, let's see what you did. Did you go Co-Rider? I went T-birds. Oh, you went T-birds. Okay, Jenna has on a black leather jacket. She's gone on a black scarf, neck scarf. You got to get that collar up, lady. I got my black leather jacket and my white shirt.
my skinny jeans. And I know the T-birds wouldn't wear a neck scarf, but I have a rash on my neck today. So I thought, let's cover it up with a silky neck scarf and just kind of go Lady T-birds. You're right on point because neck scarf is all throughout this movie. One more thing, Jenna. Ready?
I actually owned this. Don't ask me why. You have like a pink satin jacket. And when? Hello? I tried to do like the little scoopy ponytail. Oh, and the glasses. Oh, yeah. Sunglasses. Also, you wear sunglasses inside in this movie. Yes, ma'am. The only thing we're missing is bubble gum. And cigarettes.
And cigarettes. Because guess what, guys? We want to see. O-O-L and R-I-D-E-R. Well, we owe someone a very big thank you. And that person is Nathan B from New Jersey, because when I was in the general mailbox recently, I saw that Nathan wrote this. Please, please do a movie breakdown of Greece too. Oh my goodness, Nathan. We're here for you. We can't wait. So, lady, I can't remember when it was. It was a while ago.
We talked about Greece II on this podcast about how I had seen it and you had not. And I don't even remember this conversation, but it resonated and people started sending us comments and mail like Nathan asking us to watch it. Yeah, it's true. I'd never seen it. I mean, I'd seen clips of, like, the cool writer video, but I had never seen the whole movie. Well, now you have, Ange. I know.
And how'd that go for you? I mean, it is a visual feast. That's a good description. I think some of the songs are great. I think some of them are cringy. I don't know. Okay, where were you in the world when you first saw this movie? Lady, I don't remember exactly when I saw it.
I don't know if I saw it when it came out or if I saw it later. All I know is that my childhood, my sister and I loved watching Greece, and we loved watching Greece too, and we watched them both on repeat, and we would recreate the dances, and we would do all the songs. We would have my dad get out a step ladder so that we could climb the ladder, like, Stephanie and Cool Rider, yes. Oh, my gosh. You and your sister were kind of like how, like, Isabel and her friends were with Frozen.
Yes. Although there wasn't a song about reproduction. No. No. Or Greece Lightning in Greece has some, you know, innuendo. At the time when I watched Greece growing up, it went over my head. But I watched Greece too as a 54-year-old woman. And I was like, holy crap, the number of sexual innuendo songs. It's double entendres for 114 minutes, basically. All right, well, let me kick you off with a summary. And then we're going to get into some. Facts and stats. Yeah. Here's your summary. Two years after the events of Greece, we are back at Rydell High. There is a new bunch of pink ladies and tea birds and a new kid in school.
It's Michael. Michael. Sandy's sweet, straight-laced cousin from England. But when Michael falls for Stephanie, the tough leader of the pink ladies, he quickly learns that She only has eyes for dangerous guys on motorcycles. Oh, yeah. So Michael hatches a secret plan to transform himself into Rydell's mysterious new biker, the cool rider. But Greece is still the word.
Grease is the word. Mm-hmm. All right, here's some facts and stats. The runtime of this movie is 114 minutes. It was released on June 11, 1982, the same day as E.T. I read that, and I thought, that's a tough day to come out. I mean, E.T. I know. Wow. Greece was first a musical that debuted in 1971, then a film in 1978, and now we have Greece to three years later in 1982. This movie stars Michelle Pfeiffer and Maxwell Caulfield. They were both basically complete unknowns, except that Maxwell Caulfield was an up-and-coming successful theater actor.
guess what this movie did to his career? Some of the interviews made me sad. It's not great, this poor guy. He said it took him years to, like, kind of find his way back. Yeah, it kind of launched Michelle Pfeiffer and it tanked Maxwell Caulfield, but not in the hearts of people who love this movie. No, because people that love Greece, too, it is like a cult classic. We love him.
Yes, we love him. Yes. And he's fine. He's doing just fine now. He's doing great. But it was a little bit of a rough patch there. after. It was. This movie was written by Ken Finkelman. It was directed and choreographed by Patricia Birch. And this is kind of cool. Patricia Birch was the choreographer for the original musical
Greece and also for the first movie. And this was the first time a female choreographer had become a film directorial debut. It was also her only theatrical film directing credit. I'm I think this was a tough one for her. Yeah. She said that the script wasn't finished by the time they started filming. She had to start a whole movie production with an incomplete script. She didn't even know where scenes were going. Angela, how was this movie received at the box office?
Well, let's just set the stage for how much pressure this movie was under. First of all, the original Greece had a budget of $6 million. Do you know how much money it made, lady? I don't. Almost 400 million. Oh my gosh, back then. Back then. Three hundred and ninety-six million dollars and change. Wow. Yeah. So now here's Greece, too. People have high expectations. Yeah. Their budget was 11.2 million. More than Greece. Yeah. Where did the money go? I think in costumes. Guess how much it made? I'm afraid to ask. 15.2 million. No. Oh, it only made 4 million more than what it cost? It barely broke even, Lady. 15 million versus 400 million. Wow. That's tough to come back from. Well, you know, Greece, too, was supposed to be the second film in a four-film franchise. That didn't happen. No. I guess the third and fourth film were going to take place in the late 1960s in the counterculture era.
It was also going to be a TV series. They had big plans. They did. Well, there was an idea for this movie that didn't happen that I think would have been kind of cool. What's that? This is according to Wikipedia, early plans for Greece, too, had Jeff Conway and Stockard Channing's characters, Kinnechy and Rizzo as the main characters. Oh.
And this was going to be while they intended summer school. Because they flunked out. I guess. And then it was going to end with the two of them getting married. Okay. Didn't happen. Didn't happen. Would that have been better?
I don't know. I don't know. Well, now I'm sort of part of the cult following, you know? I love to hear it. Yeah, I just can't see anyone else but Michelle Pfeiffer and Maxwell Culfield now. Yeah. Yeah. Do you want to know what the critics thought of this movie?
Oh, no. Well, it has a 37% on Rotten Tomatoes. Okay. And Roger Ebert wrote this little gem, quote, The movie seems assembled off the shelf. He's not wrong. There are no inspired. songs in it. Oh, I disagree. Disagree. The big dance numbers seem to be exercises in crowd
control. That did make me laugh. There are like literally hundreds of people dancing at all times. And the story is this idiotic. It depends on how long it will take Michelle Pfeiffer to figure out that Caulfield is the guy behind the mask. This movie just recycles grease without the stars, without the energy, without the freshness, and without the grease. Oh, that's brutal. I also, I take issue with one of his criticisms. I'm sorry, the entire Superman franchise is based on everyone not realizing that Clark Kent... With a pair of glasses.
Is not Superman. Just because of a pair of glasses, I would say it was, you know, kind of hard to figure out who he was. His helmet is big. It covers most of his whole head and his goggles are enormous. And did you notice he does a faky American accent? That's right. This is way more camouflage than Superman. Way more!
Well, they also wanted a catchier title than Greece, too. I'm not sure it would have helped because these two are not great options. Ready? What are they? According to the internet, one was more grease. I don't like that. No. That's making me uncomfortable.
No. It gives me the ick. No one wants more grease. The other one was Son of Greece. Oh, that feels like a Monty Python spoof of grease. grease. It doesn't even make sense. Like, I don't get it. Also, because their sun isn't in it. I know. Okay. Okay. Here would be my alt title. What is it? Collar up, cigarettes, and sunglasses. I mean, that's a great tagline. That would have been great on the poster. They should have put you on the
marketing team. Do you want to know what's on the actual grease two poster? What? The music and feeling go on forever. I like yours way better. Yeah. Mine is spik. It invokes more of the tone of the movie. Yeah. For sure. All right. Well, I think we should go to break. And when we come back, we've got an enormous opening number.
Huge. That's what she said. All right. The movie opens up. It's the early 60s. We have a huge establishing shot of Rydale High School. Principal, Miss McGee and Blanche, the assistant principal, they are walking out and they're going to put up the school. The school flag, it reads Rydell High School, 1961.
First Day of School. First day of school. And these are flashback characters from original Greece. Yes. Already, I'm happy. The first line of the movie. It's a voiceover by Principal McGee. This is how we're going to kick off this movie.
I found it interesting. Are you ready? A new school year, Blanche. A new era. If the Russians can put a man in space, Just imagine what our young American minds can do at Rydell. It's amazing. It is a theme throughout the movie is Russia and nuclear...
Possible nuclear attacks, shelters, sirens. Yeah. Like you said, these gals are back from the original movie. Eve Arden plays Principal McGee. She is an absolute legend. She was nominated for an Academy Award. She won an Emmy Award. She has two stars on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
Two! Yes, one for radio and one for TV. She was also a radio personality. Wow. And then Judy Goodman, who plays Blanche, she did a ton of theater. She was a regular comedic guest on the Tonight Show. Yep. And she was on the Mary Tyler Moore show. And she was nominated for an Emmy for Listen to This Category. Best Continuing Performance in a series by a comedian, singer, hostess, dancer, MC announcer, narrator, panelist, or any person who has, essentially plays herself. Is that all etched on the trophy? I don't know. How do they fit that on the plaque? I don't know. I would watch that woman play the xylophone all day long.
Lady, I kind of thought that if they remade this movie today, that you and hire would play Miss McGee and Blaine. I want to be played it so badly. I wouldn't be Miss McGee. And what you just swat at me is I continue playing the xylophone. I'll be so flummoxed. Oh. Well, anyway, these two agree, it's going to be a great school year. And just as they agree, you hear the sound of screeching tires and a crash. And we cut to the pink ladies arriving in their pink car. Yeah, they're not good at driving, guys. They screech and come to a halt several times in the movie. But their leader is late. Yeah. Why didn't she ride with them? Why can't they pick her up?
Maybe she didn't like to ride with them. I don't know. Maybe she doesn't trust their driving. Maybe not. But this is our first glimpse of Michelle Pfeiffer, who was 23 years old when they filmed Greece. And now we're going to have our big opening song and dance number back to school again. The choreography for this number is so impressive. The song is also really catchy.
I read that there were 20 main dancers for all the numbers. But then to fill out the whole thing, there were almost 500 cast members. I believe it. It's unreal. I don't know how. you direct something of that scope. I don't know how you dress everybody. This is an amazing feat for the casting crew.
What asked what her favorite number was from the movie, the director and choreographer, Patricia Birch, said this. I think the opening of Greece, too, is one of the best things anybody's ever done. I managed to do what, a seven-minute, non-stop informational number. That's where you got to know them. I love that opening, yeah. It's a good opening.
I know it's a good opening. I so agree with her. She is right. The opening of this movie is perfection. It's everything you want in a big musical number. And the song is called Back to School. Let's hear a little bit of it. How catchy is that? It's so great.
Well, like Patricia Birch said, during this whole dance number, we're meeting everybody. We're understanding the relationships. Lady, I have to tell you. What? Do you know who our first caller-up moment is? Is it when all of the T-birds arrive? No, it's actually Stephanie. Oh, she puts her collar up.
Yes. She's our first collar up. I will be tracking collars and sunglasses, just so you guys know. Well, she has both. She does. And at three minutes, 48 seconds, we meet the T-birds. Here's what you need to be a member. You need a leather jacket that doesn't move with your body, right?
It's so stiff. You need cigarettes, lots of them. You need sunglasses, and you need poofy hair that comes to a point in the middle of your forehead. Yep. You're ready. You got it. Do you want a T-Bird Breakdown? I sure do.
Good, because I've got it for you. Adrian Zamede plays Johnny Nogorelli, the leader of the T-birds. He was 27 years old when he shot this movie. And incidentally, he played Danny Zucco in Greece on Broadway. So he actually, like, originated the role of Danny Zuko. Oh, what a full-circle moment for him. I know. That's really cool.
DiMucci is played by Peter Frenchet. Goose is played by Christopher McDonald. You know him from Thelman-Louise. Happy Gilmore. And Davy is played by Leaf Green. Now we're going to meet Miss Mason, the hot music teacher. She seems to teach a lot of classes. Well, she also teaches English.
I know. This was, I was like, she also has time to go to Mr. Stewart's classes, apparently. Yes, she doesn't sit in. And she also loves hairspray. She's carrying two cans of hairspray. Two, yes. And she's constantly spraying her hair. So don't get too close to her.
You're going to breathe that in. Yes. Miss Mason was played by. Connie Stevens, everyone. Connie Stevens, who once dated Elvis Presley. I read that. I know. Like, for a while, and she loved him.
Yeah. And then her second husband was once married to Elizabeth Taylor. Eddie Fisher. Her daughter is Jolie Fisher, the actress. This is wild. I know. Also, I do want to note, the T-birds are very flirty with Miss Mason. Oh, yes.
Ms. Mason says, I'd love to see you all in music appreciation. And Johnny, he says, I'd like to see all of you in music appreciation. And Ms. Mason says, you just might. I mean, this is very spicy. Very spicy. They can also see her in English class, which she also teaches, by the way. All right, well, we're going to get to this credit sequence, and this is where we're going to meet Maxwell Caulfield playing Michael. He was 22 years old.
He gets first billing. Wow. Yeah. I would have thought that if they were sort of like a. equal experience or status in the world of Hollywood, which it seemed like he and Michelle Pfeiffer were. I sort of see this as a little bit more of Stephanie's story. Do you see it as Michael's? I mean, I think it's the two of them, honestly. Yeah, it's a two-hander. It's a two-hander. I did see this very charming interview with Maxwell Culfield. A few cast members also shared
how supportive the original cast was of everyone in Greece, too. I love hearing that. They said it was like a family. Like they were like the big brother, big sister, and they were like the little siblings, and that Olivia Newton-John, in particular, hosted a few parties and invited all the cast. Wow. Where to go, Olivia Newton-John? I know. Well, you know, her boyfriend was in the movie.
I know. We'll get to it. We'll get to it. All right, we're going to meet Michael. We're going to learn he's Sandy's cousin, and he's going to run into Frenchie. Yes, we love Frenchie. That's a flashback character. Played by D.D. Con.
Frenchie explains everything that's happened since she left Rydell. We find out she flunked out of beauty school because in tinting class, her hair turned pink, and that now the most important thing in her life is skin care. So she's back at Rydell to get her chemistry and to mix her own cosmetics. This is a lot of information about a character who is going to disappear halfway through the film. She's just got to establish why she's back at high school. I guess. But she probably could have done it in one sentence.
Yeah, it's a lot. No judgment. Just. Well, listen, through all of this, we're still dancing. We're still singing. And now we're going to hear the pink ladies pledge, and I thought we should hear it because I love it, and I can't get it out of my head. The pink ladies pledge to act cool, to look cool, and to be cool till death it was part,
think pink. Yeah, that's the pink lady's pledge. Do you feel like Victoria's secrets kind of stole the think pink? I think they did. Yeah. I've been thinking about that for days. Yeah, me too. I'm glad you said it.
Well, there it is. It's on record. Here's your Pink Ladies' breakdown. Stephanie Zanoni, leader of the Pink Ladies, played by Michelle Pfeiffer, Paulette Rebchuk, played by Lorna Luffed, Rhonda Ritter, played by Alison Price, Sharon Cooper, played by Maureen Teefe and Dolores Rebchuk, who is Paulette's little sister, played by Pamela Adlon. And now we're going to see the coach, played by Sid Caesar,
another returning character. Yep, Coach Calhoun. Mm-hmm. There's more dancing. So much dancing. Everyone dances inside. The T-Birds stop to comb their hair, though. That's very important to them.
Yeah. They have to fix their hair a lot. And then this whole thing ends. This is like a moment that is burned in my brain from my childhood. It ends with a guy running across. The lawn. It's just diving through an open window. Yeah.
Of the high school. And then that ends on like a downbeat. It's like, boom. Yeah. And now we've opened. open to the movie. Yeah, and there's a cello hanging from the flagpole. A bunch of kids are hanging out the windows. The school is a little wackadoodle. Well, at the lockers, the pink ladies discuss nose jobs. They discuss who JFK would rather be with if it's Jackie O or Marilyn Monroe.
Johnny, the head of the T-birds, comes over, and Stephanie has to remind him, it's over, Johnny. Yeah. We're over. Paulette clearly likes Johnny. Nine minutes, 13 seconds. We have another very big collar up. moment, courtesy of Johnny in a stiff leather jacket. That's great. Lewis is going to come over and give Sharon a big old smooch at the lockers. I know. Real big kiss.
These two are on. There's a lot of people kissing in close proximity to other people in this movie. So if you don't like PDA, this movie is a little bit of a cringe fest for you. This is not the high school for you. No. Well, Stephanie starts to go to class, but then she realizes she's wearing jeans. and so she goes to her locker to change into a skirt. Yeah, she's got like these little, like what did they call them?
Pedal pusher, like leggings, right? Yeah, like little cigarette pants. Cigarette pants. Well, I got to wondering, was this a real thing that girls in the 60s couldn't wear pants to school, even public school? Yeah, I noticed Stephanie looks around and sees all the other girls in skirts and then quickly grabs her skirt. I deep dived it. What was the rule? I found this amazing Reddit thread called Ask Old People.
Oh. One of the threads was about this very subject, people asking, was it a rule that girls had to wear skirts to school? And according to the old people, the answer is yes. Prior to 1970, girls had to wear dresses or skirts that went down to their knees. One person said the hem of the dress had to touch the floor if you were kneeling. Okay. That's how you knew if it was the right length. girls could not wear pants, jeans, shorts, and also no open-toed shoes.
One woman said she had to wear panty hose, quote, in an un-air-conditioned classroom in Texas. And then I found this comment in the thread, and I loved it. This old person said, I graduated from high school in 1970, and it was only during the last few months of that year that I ever wore pants to school. A girl named Nancy just showed up one day in pants. Go, Nancy. And when she got sent to the principal's office, she calmly made her case. At some point, he, of course it was a he, was persuaded. I never knew what she said exactly, but I know she was a smart, even-tempered girl who had an older sister. They were being raised by their dad because their mom had died, which gave them both a sort of gravity. After this conversation with the principal, she went back to class and finished her day, and they made an announcement that girls could now wear pants. Wow. I can't really describe when it impact that event had on all of us, but me in particular.
You could ask why. You could make an argument. You could persuade people with power over you to change. That girl was a legend. Wherever you are, Nancy, thanks. That's awesome. Pretty cool. Incidentally, this thread also said that boys had to wear shirts with collars.
They had to be tucked in, and their hair couldn't be longer than the tops of their ears, maybe that's why the T-birds put all their hair up so high. And then let it droop down their forehead. Right. There was no rule about forehead hair. They could compensate in the front. They weren't allowed to have facial hair either. Well, now Michael is trying to find a locker and he's chosen one of the T-Birds lockers, and they are going to intimidate him by harmonizing. Yes. They harmonize at him. They do. Well, Stephanie sees all this, and she looks at my and she says, it's okay, it's going to be all right. And now he's done for. He's totally smitten. I mean, he's going to get even more smitten, but he had a lightning bolt moment with her.
Yeah, it was immediate. Yeah. Well, now we're in one of Ms. Mason's classrooms, if she is many, or does she use one and she just rotates? I don't know. I don't know. Of course it's her class. It's her class. And we hear over the intercom, Principal McGee, you know, she's making an announcement. Blanche is playing the Zyel xylophone. And she says, listen, everyone, there's lots of extracurriculars, and we want you all to try out for things. And then she says, and we'd like to welcome a new straight-A student, Michael Carrington. And then Ms. Mason has the whole entire class be like, hi, Michael. I had this happen to me. You did? It's horrifying. Yeah. So teachers out there, don't single out the new kid like that. I was new moved from Indonesia to Dallas in the 80s, and the teacher was like, we have a new student today all the way from Indonesia.
And everyone was like, who is the freak show? And I was like, hi. Yeah. No, please don't call attention to me. Just let me be the new kid on my own terms. Yeah, I get it. Well, now we're going to go out to the fields. I guess it's track practice.
It's band practice. It's football practice. Yeah. The twin cheerleaders want Michael to play piano for their talent show auditions. So, lady, there's a pretty big wardrobe malfunction that happens during that conversation behind Michael and the cheerleaders. What? In the background? In the background, at around 14 minutes, there are some dudes running on the track and jumping over hurdles. And on the left side of the screen, one of the hurdlers... What happens? His wiener pops up?
No, he doesn't. What are you saying? He quickly tucks it back in. No. Yes. Is this? There's a lot of scuttle butt online about it. People have put it in a, like, a meme, a TikTok.
It's on Twitter. It's all over the place. This poor guy. This poor guy. And I did go and watch to see if it's true. And I, you do see something, find its way out, and then he quickly tucks it back in. Oh, here, Matt just sent us a picture of it. Wait.
Oh, my God. Oh, it's a nut. It's, I think, a little bit of beans and franks, a little bit. It's definitely, it's. Yeah. Definitely the beans. Yeah. Beans are out.
I, yes, so, wow. That happened. This poor guy. I know. How did they not see that in the editing? I mean, there's so many continuity errors in this movie. Don't even get me started to, like, who's in the pool, who's out of the pool later on. Okay.
All right, well, listen, now after he agrees to play piano at the talent auditions, right? Yes. Michael asked Frenchie about Stephanie, but she says you can only date Stephanie if you're a T-bird, and he says, how do you become a T-bird? And then, as if enough isn't happening on this field, a rival biker gang shows up. Yes, led by Leo Belmudo, aka Craterface, played by Dennis Stewart, who is the same guy from Greece that used to bother the T-birds. Right. In Greece, he drove a car, and he was leader of the Scorpions gang. But now in Greece, too, he is the leader of the motorcycle gang called Wait for it.
It's so bad. Cycle Lords. The Cycle Lords. It's not an intimidating name. The Scorpions was a better name, I think. Get out of the way. The Psycholords are coming. Well, the T-birds, they throw their leather jackets on top of their gym shirts.
They light a cigarette. Yeah. And they walk over and they're like, we can't rumble with you tonight because tonight we bowl. Yeah. We're bowling tonight. And the cycle lords are like, oh, I guess they're busy bowling. We're not going to fight them now. Yeah.
Respect for the bowling. Yeah. And then Johnny says to Paulette, he wants her to, quote, look special tonight. He's flirting with Paulette. He does this whole thing through this whole movie where he flirts with Paulette and then he flirts with Stephanie. And then he flirts with Stephanie. He full on kisses Paulette in front of Stephanie. And then it's like, Stephanie, why don't you want to be with me?
Like, what? Yeah, this guy's all over the place. All right. Should we go to the bowling alley? because this is the piesta resistance of this film, in my opinion. This is just an amazing moment in cinema. It was also Patricia Birch's second favorite number because the musical number and the dancing are, again, phenomenal. The song is called Score Tonight.
It's our first real sexual innuendo song. Yes. Because bowling leads to a little in the sack, apparently. The scoring. The scoring. Right. So there's a bunch of students there bowling. There are also some nuns in full habits bowling.
Yes. The nuns are bowling, and they have beef with the team they're bowling against. I zoomed in on their outfits. They like shake their fists at each other. And I'm like, who did the nuns not like? Who are they bowling against? And they're wearing like sort of these brown gingham tops, and they have like this little emblem.
It looks like of some kind of Roman helmet. I don't know who they are. Well, they're not getting along. I guess. No. That's amazing. Speaking of these costumes, I would love to give a shout out to the costume department headed by Robert Demora. I cannot imagine dressing this many people for a movie.
I'm going to be highlighting a few costumes throughout. I would say the best dress for this particular number goes to Paulette. A hundred percent, those gold pants. My gosh. She's in the pink gingham personalized button down pink lady blouse with gold trim. and like you said, the most glittery, super, very tight gold pants. Also, the collar up moment goes to Paulette as well, but the sunglasses and side moment goes to Stephanie.
Well, I think we need to hear a little bit of score tonight. Last game coming up, winter take all agreed? But did you shoot the ball? Shoot the ball. Shoot the ball. Knock them down. I'm going to show you how it's done. So fun.
So that leads into a giant dance break. We are spinning. We are pirouetting. We are high kicking. We are toe touching. Everybody has a bowling ball. They're spinning with their bowling ball. These are clearly faky balls.
They weigh nothing. No. People are looking around. No one's even trying to make them look like they weigh anything. They just throw them up above their heads. They spin with them. I think one of the things that makes this song so great are the vocals on Adrian Zemad. I mean, when you hear him singing at the beginning, he's just crushing it.
Yeah. And also, Lorna Luffed. And I want to play a clip that starts with this high note by Adrian Zemad and leads into Lorna Luf's section of this song. Let's take a look over here. I'm your kingpin, honey, and I'm getting engaged. I mean, am I right? Yeah. The voices on these two.
Absolutely amazing. Well, it makes sense because Lorna Lept, this was her theatrical film debut, but she is daughter of Judy Garland. She is the half-sister of Liza Minnelli. It runs in the family, clearly. Yeah. Incidentally, did you know that Cher was originally signed on to play Paulette Rebchuk, but she backed out. She said the salary was too low and they didn't have a finished script. Cher was like, I think I'm going to pass. I think I'm out. Well, Lorna Left crushes it. There is a dance move in this number I need to talk about. Which one is it? There's so many. It's called, I'm annoyed, but I'm still going to dance.
Okay. Who does it? Stephanie. Oh, yeah. She's so annoyed, you know, but she's like, fine, more dance. Well, I'm going to pout about it. It's pretty amazing. Like, I want to do that dance move.
Also, a lot of people online called bullshit on dancing on the bowling lanes. This is what some folks said. Quote, everybody is dancing at the bowling alley and even dancing on the alleys. The alleys in a bowling alley. are heavily waxed so the bowling balls don't have friction while rolling. Everyone dancing on the alleys would be slipping, sliding, and falling all over the place. Well, I want to offer maybe this is why they can spin so much. They spin with ease. I think they would be bust in their ass. Many people wrote about that. One other thing I'd love to share is that Michelle Pfeiffer said in an interview
that she kept her bowling ball. Oh. From this movie and still has it. Well, outside, Michael is What is happening here, okay? He's got some type of book, like a manual that tells you how to talk to people about bowling. Yeah, I wrote down the suggestions from the book. I did too. Always be courteous when asking for a game. Hi, want a game? Howdy, fellas?
Let's bowl some balls. Bowling anyone? What is this book? There were a lot of pages in this book. I have to think that it addresses more than bowling. I hope so. But also, wow, that there's even a section. Well, inside everyone is now done bowling.
They're walking up to return their shoes. Johnny wants a trophy for winning because they won. Yeah. So Paulette goes over, she gives them a big, long smooch. Yeah. And he's like, that's great. That was the trophy for best average. Then he turns to Stephanie and he says,
how about a kiss for best score? And Stephanie says, I ain't no one's. trophy. And he says, so that's the way it's going to be now, huh, Miss Independent? And she says, yeah, independent. I kiss who I want, when I want. I could kiss the next guy who walks through that door if I want. And he says, be my guest. Well, guess who walks in right at that moment? Michael. And she lays one on him. He's shocked. Everyone's shocked. Then she walks over to the group, and she says, let's eat. Mm-hmm.
Wow. This scene, that whole line of, that's the way it's going to be now, huh? Miss Independent. She's like, yeah, independent. My sister and I used to do the dialogue from this scene. That's adorable. Some of my favorite dialogue from the movie.
That's so cute, lady. Well, our next big scene is a new day at school. We're going to meet Mr. Stewart. I'm sorry, but before that, we're going to see the pink ladies arrive again without Stephanie. And I just want to say I don't understand. understand why they can't drive Stephanie to school. I don't know. Is that when they almost crash into the tree? Yeah. I don't think she likes to ride with them, lady. Okay, fine. They almost run over Mr.
Stewart upon arriving. Mr. Stewart very quickly meets Miss Mason, aka Sexy McSexe, and he says he likes her hair. She loves her hair. She's got great hair. Mr. Stewart was played by Tab Hunter. So incidentally, both Connie Stevens and Tab Hunter, they were like, matinee idols when they were younger. So the casting of these two was kind of a nod to the older audience. It reminds me a little bit of us and Lee's movie, Angela. It's a movie about young people and rock and roll. And a few recognizable oldies. Yes, they sprinkle in some matinee idols of the past. And that's me and you. And Fred Armisen and Bobby Lee, I think. Our job in Lee's movie. I would do it all day long. It's super fun to be the old. these on set. And we find out about the big talent show. It's the Rydell Review. Prices are
100 long playing records. The T-birds really want them. Yeah, they do. Well, now we're going to get to this little bit in the hallway between Johnny and the principal. She's scolding him about riding motorcycles across the school lawn. And the whole time, he's hiding a cigarette in his mouth. Yeah, he's smoking as she walks up and he does the thing where he folds it into his mouth. Yeah, this would drive me crazy. I would have to skip this scene. I don't care for it. I don't care for I don't like it, that then his friend slaps him on the back and he swallows it. This would make my sister and I crazy this scene. Well, I looked up how they did this gag.
And according to the internet, actor Adrian Zemad confirmed it was a real cigarette, not a special effect. The bit was written into the movie by Ken Finkelman who did this in high school. So Zemad practiced this trick every day for roughly two months before shooting the scene. He did hold the cigarette in his mouth, but he did not swallow it, Jenna. That is crazy to me. I assumed that he did the flip, I believed it, and then I assumed they took it out, and that whole time that he was talking to Miss McGee, he was just pretending to hop up. That makes it even harder for me to watch now, knowing that the cigarette was in his mouth the whole time.
He did say when the camera came onto his back, he didn't have the cigarette in his mouth anymore. Well, thank God. But when he was facing forward, he did. Wow. Well, let's get to these talent show auditions, lady. First, we have a riveting song about a guy named Brad. by the twins with Michael on piano. So this guy, Brad, was played by Matt Lentanzi.
He had a small part in Zanadu the year before where he met Olivia Newton-John. And then he got cast in Greece, too. And this whole time he was Olivia Newton-John's boyfriend. They actually ended up getting married. They had a daughter. They divorced after 11 years of marriage. But maybe this is why she was hosting all those parties. because her boyfriend was in the movie.
Yeah. But also, I mean, Lorna Luff said that just the whole cast was so warm to them. I believe it. Well, now we have the pink ladies. They're going to audition. Their song is Calendar Girls. Michael is playing the piano again.
Sharon is clearly running the show. The role of Sharon was originally going to be played by Jennifer Beals, but she left to take the lead role in Flash Dance. Oh. But I think if I was going to be in this movie, Like when I was younger, I would have played Sharon. I love this line that she says to Rhonda. She goes, Rhonda, your fall.
Give me maturity. Give me aging. Rhonda's like, give me a break. Who would you have played, lady? Maybe Paulette. I could see you as Paulette. You'd be great. Thanks.
Well, the Calendar Girl song, I find it so grating. It's hard for me. I really hate the beginning with the a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a. So I'm going to play a clip. You're playing the song you hate? Yeah, because it's going to lead into a really cringy conversation between Michael and Stephanie. Hi. I wanted to ask you if you're free after school today.
Yeah, I'm free every day. It's in the Constitution. Yeah, that's another line we would always quote. Yeah, I'm free every day. It's in the Constitution. Yeah. The pink ladies get cut off after just one season, and Sharon is really upset. But Michael's going to hit up Stephanie again after the song, but she's too busy to go out.
She's very busy. He'd like to know, like, what was up with the bowling alley? And she's like, that was a joke. Okay, get over it. Yeah. Yeah. And then she forgot her book. So he asked her again.
He says, how about the day after tomorrow? And she can't take it. And she's going to explain what she's actually looking for in a guy. I think we should hear it. If you really want to know with Helen his eye, I want a devil when fine now, I'll be holding on. Here's the thing. She is so dynamic when she's singing.
There's like this spotlight on her. Her eyes are on fire. She has this amazing red lipstick. She's so intense. She's completely captivating. She is. She's wearing all black. She has a black top, black tight pants, black bangle bracelets.
Her pink lady jacket is reversible lady. She's wearing it in black. Oh. But if Michael didn't know. really what she's into, her necklace is a dead giveaway. Why? What is it? It's a gold necklace with a motorcycle pendant. Well, here's the thing. I wrote down, I think this is why she got the part. Holy shit. She's amazing. All during this first section of the song, there were these weird cutaways to Michael listening to her sing, and he's a complete, like, just blank slate. But then
something happens. What? Then she starts dancing. Well, I learned one of her dance moves. I'd like to show it to you now. Oh, God. Please. No, that's the one I can't take at the end. Here's the thing.
I have compassion for her because I'm looking at this whole scene through the camera lens, and she's got to cover a lot of ground in a short amount of time. So she does this weird scooching dance move. I don't know how else you cover that amount of ground unless you can do cartwheels and stuff. But I was curious what Michelle Pfeiffer had to say about her audition process. I was curious about her background
for singing and dancing. And I found this interview of her on the James Corden show. Here's what she had to say. Now, what was your audition process like for Greece too? Well, it was a total fluke that I got that part. And I went on a lark. I mean, my agent said,
oh, just go. I wasn't a dancer. I wasn't a singer. And I was in this little short purple skirt with go-go boots. And we had the dancing auditions. And, you know, it's literally like a chorus line. It's like this line goes. And then the next line goes. And I kept sneaking in the back. And finally, it was only me. Sure. And the director's like, come on, come on. So I go and, you know, go down there. But anyway, I did. And I got. the part and I, you know, shockingly enough. And then we all got given Greece too. And how could we mad about that?
I mean, she was surprised. Well, here's what I wrote down. I wrote, she's so sexy when she's singing. And then she is so not sexy when they make her dance. And I just wrote, let this woman sing. Why did this need to be a dance? number. It was so good. Because later, we're going to let Michael wax on for three minutes about his charade. He doesn't have to dance through that song. His whole ballad that, like, I can't even take.
It's just a giant montage. Why couldn't she just stand there and sing, like, the powerhouse that she is? And the thing is that, like, when you're seeing her face and her eyes, the singing sounds great, leave her alone. Don't make this woman dance anymore. I would say don't make her do any more. than the ladder. The ladder was very impressive. The ladder is tall. It's got a tiny little top of the ladder that then she had to like kind of move around on. I was terrified for her. And then the way she comes off that ladder is the coolest thing I've ever seen. With her big sweeping leg. I would have wiped out. I would have absolutely face planted. Because she goes down a few, then up a few and then down a few more and then up one. Yes. Just leave her on the ladder.
In fact, you know what you don't make her do when she's on the top of the ladder, which again kills the whole ladder bit, the jazz hands. Why the jazz hands? Why is it? This is not sexy. I'm sorry. Like if you're dancing for your husband and you're being sexy and then you start doing jazz hands, it's gone.
Or if he likes jazz hands, maybe there's another conversation to be had. I mean, sure. Maybe you have a thing for jazz hands, but I just think there's, you can't be sexy while doing jazz hands. There's not a single stripper who does jazz hands. I'm convinced. No one's doing it. It's not happening.
I just also think that there's maybe a reason the latter was part of this move because maybe they saw her do the scoge move. And they were like, we need a prop. It was great. Yeah. But it all falls apart when she, oh, God. Anyway, I both, I love cool rider, but the dancing is hard. That's all we have to say about that. I think we should take a break.
and then when we come back. Michael has figured out a way to buy a motorcycle, and it includes selling essays and homework. I break down the math of it. Oh. When we come back. Great. We are back, and like Angela said before the break,
the T-birds are going to start asking Michael to do their homework for them. It's a secret. It's a secret. They got a rep to protect. Exactly. They all are very worried about their reps. Yes.
their rep of doing their own homework? I don't know. I don't know. But he's doing it so that he can earn money to buy a motorcycle. Yeah. Louie comes to what we learn is Michael's uncle's nuclear fallout shelter, where I guess Michael hangs out and does his homework? Yeah, I said, does he live in his uncle's fallout shelter or just do his homework in there?
I don't know. Either way, kind of makes me sad. But Louie comes there, he looks around and is like, oh, this is a good place to do. do homework on other things. I'm like, great. It looks like he pays Michael what appears to be $5 for this essay. For this essay. I looked up what a motorcycle costs in 1961. Okay. On the low end, $800. I mean, he gets a pretty junkie motorcycle that he has to fix up through a series of montages. He goes to like basically a junkyard. Yeah. So if he got one that's $800, it'd be about 160 essays.
Oh my. There can't possibly be that many. There's only four T-birds. I know. I think you got a real piece of junk. I mean. Well, now we go to a biology lesson by Mr. Stewart. With Miss Mason in the room.
It's got the famous, where does the pollen go? Yes. This is the song Reproduction. Let's hear the beginning of it. Reproduction. Reproduction. Reproduction. I got your pistol right here.
Back here. Don't you get in your seat. Yeah, there you go. You've got this whole number now. The boys are all on one side of the room. The girls are on the other side of the room. The girls are doing that sort of stereotypical back in the day sort of thing of being both like sort of sexy, but also the gatekeepers of sex. The boys are just like, you know, letcherists and wanting to get it on.
There is one moment, though, where the girls pretend to be the boys and the boys pretend to be the girls. The boys are like, oh, you always say now. And the girls are like, yeah, I do this. So I did appreciate that moment. We did have a little role reversal there. Yeah. Catchy song. My sister and I were too shy to sing this one.
I get it. We wouldn't do this one. You didn't want to sing about the pollen tubes? I guess we didn't. But then, ironically, we would belt out. Let's do it for our country. which is coming up. Guess what, everybody?
Michael has enough money for a motorcycle. He fixes it up by reading a manual. This kid has got so many manuals. He's very smart. And he's going to practice writing it in the park. Frenchie looks on. She's concerned. At the end, he like pulls away, and then he looks over his shoulder at her.
He's wearing like his mechanics jumpsuit. Oh, this, I was dead. Like, he is so cute. This is the look that got it for you? This is the one. This is the Maxwell Caulfield, posters going on my wall. This look. There's another one, too.
Okay, mine comes later. It involves a turquoise sweater. Oh, I know it. There is now a montage, you guys, with a passage of time. You know, we find out everyone made the talent show because I guess they didn't have enough people sign up. We see people practicing for the talent show. We see Michael working on his bike, tinkering with his bike, trying to learn how to pop a wheelie, things like that. Yeah, the T-birds are really intimidated by the Mr. Sandman Trio.
The Sandman T-M trio are singing in the showers. They're harmonizing in the showers and the T-birds are worried. Are they really going to win the records? Yeah. These guys are good. Those guys are real good. Now the montage is over and we're back at the bowling alley. The rival gang, you guys, you know, the cycle.
Lords. Yeah. They're going to surprise the T-birds. There's so many cycle lords. This is not an even match. Here's the thing. So just the leader is outside. And as Dolores walks in, she calls him scum and she runs in and tells the T-birds, he's outside and he's all alone. So then the T-birds go outside, but by the time they get there, the whole rival gang is there. All of the lords are there. How many are there of them? Yeah. But as you've mentioned, it's like 20 against four. They start to rough up Davy. Yeah. And then the mysterious writer appears.
Yeah. All hell breaks loose. Yeah. There's this shot of everybody inside the clear bowling alley doors. Watching. I wrote down, I cannot even imagine the nightmare this shot was for continuity. Also, clearly, they had people like on. Rizers, yes.
Yeah. Because how were they so tall? They fill the whole thing. Cinematically, it's a really cool shot. It is. It took a lot of work, though. So they are watching out these glass doors as this single mysterious motorcycle guy takes on this whole gang. The whole gang.
None of them can catch them. 20 versus 1. They can't get them. Also, they suddenly just can't ride their motorcycles. All he does is ride by and they fall over. They fall. I know. They're like, Amaget.
Now everyone spills out of the doors. they're all in the parking lot now. Well, wait, we have to talk about the song that's going on this whole time. Who's that guy? I know. Stephanie is instantly fascinated, clearly turned on by this mysterious writer. This starts what I'm calling acting with bubble gum portion of the movie. Oh, does she have a lot of bubble gum in this one?
What? Are you crazy? She's popping big bubbles. She's pulling it out of her mouth and stringing it back. fourth. She's chomping on it nervous. Chomping on it nervous. She pops it, rolls her eyes. She pops it sexy. There's so much gum acting here. I do not notice it. Oh my gosh. My personal favorite part of this song is the part where Michael sings about himself in the third person. I thought we should hear it because this song is great. I also wrote down how you sing this song with zero irony.
I don't know. What would they say if they knew it was Michael? That's him while he's taking on the gang. That's him. But he also sounds a little bit like Cartman from South Park. Like, dude, it's Michael. Oh, my God. It's really crazy.
It's really crazy. Well, anyway, he does it. He defeats them. He does. And then we lead into us. scene that I love. Stephanie, she can't stop just staring off into space. And the pink ladies have to come over. And this is a scene called There's Been Talk. Wait. What? I love that scene, but before that happens, my favorite line, maybe in the movie, happens. What is it? Johnny is pissed off.
Mysterious writer has messed with his mojo. And he goes, everyone inside, we bowl. It's so good. All right, well, now let's hear There's been talk. You know, Steph, there's been talk. We haven't been talking. But there has been talk, Steph, questioning your loyalty to the birds.
Well, it doesn't mean that you gotta go steady with Johnny. In fact, I think it's better for the both of you that it's over. Yeah, but the code does say that we're cheap. At least till grand. Let's go, Lewis. Yeah, well, maybe I'm tired of being someone's chick. Tired at being someone's chick. Are you feeling okay?
I don't know what I'm feeling. Here, have a siggy. Maybe it'll make you feel better. Yeah, I love it. I love all that dialogue. I think it's great. Have a siggy. Have a siggy.
Paulette offers her a siggy, but she can't get it lit. She can't. But guess who can light it? The cool rider. He offers her a ride. She can't believe it. But then the cops show
up and he says, some other time. And then he jumps the entire cop car. Yeah. Stephanie's about to come undone. I think we do need to discuss the mysterious writer's wardrobe. It is no shirt. Yes, it's no shirt under, but with a leather jacket. Leather jacket, very unzipped, though, like halfway down to his belly button to show off his chest. When he offers to light her cigarette, you can see his breath. So I know it was cold that night. But yeah, mysterious writer. Yeah. Johnny sees all of this, by the way, and he is really upset.
Yeah, there's this weird shot of him at the end taking it all in. Also, we should note he is doing an American accent. When he's the mysterious writer. When he offers her a ride. Yeah. All right, well, it's the next day. Michael is hanging out with Frenchie in the science lab. Oh, she's heard all about it.
Oh, yeah. He's like it was me. Yeah. And she's like, you knocked her socks off as the cool writer. But when you're yourself, you knock her socks back on. Oh, that's a great line. I know. Well, the pink ladies walk in. Michael claims that he's got confidence from the night before. He's going to ask her out as Michael.
Yeah. So he's going to go and he's going to have this sexy lead-off question. He's like, hey, you ever read a Superman comic? And she says, not in the last few hours. This is your go-to leadoff line? Mm-hmm. You've ever read a Superman comic? Michael.
Yeah. Michael. So listen, you're not going to see Frenchie again. She's done. Oh, that's right. You're not going to see her at the end of the movie. She just sort of disappears now. And in a 2003 interview, D.D. Con explained that the reason Frenchie disappears halfway through the movie is because the script was not finished when they began filming.
The draft they started with included Frenchie, but the character was written out. She was told halfway through the movie that she was no longer needed. They did decide to include Frenchie in the final cut, but they had very limited footage. She described the entire filming process as rushed, frantic, and unorganized. Yeah. So anyway, that's the end of Frenchie. Well, now Louie is going to sneak into Michael's uncle's nuclear fallout shelter to try to trick Sharon into sleeping with him. Yeah, he has the other T-birds go outside the shelter and crank, like, the alarm.
The siren. Yeah. Yeah. Mm-hmm. They're going to have this duet called Let's Do It for Our Country. Yeah. You can imagine what that entails. Yes.
She's going to get wise to him at the end, and she's like, I'm out of here. She's upset. But there's this whole thing where she's, like, wrapping him up in gauze and stuff. She thinks she's healing his. Like Florence Nightingale or something? Before he goes off to war. Mm-hmm. I guess she's going to wrap him in some gauze.
and then have sex with him. I don't know. I'm not sure. All right. You know. Well, now we're at the gas station. Yes, the only mechanic in this whole movie is Stephanie. It's her dad's gas station.
Because in Greece, you know, the greasers are mechanics. Mm-hmm. So Stephanie is that for this movie. Well, she's very overwhelmed. She has multiple people asking her for things. They're very annoyed patrons at this gas station. Yes. I don't understand why she doesn't.
finish one thing at a time. She starts three different customers things. Like, just finish it and then move to the next person. But instead, she's got three unfinished businesses all yelling at her. All yelling at her. Gas is, I would like to point out, 50 cents a gallon. Michael pulls up, he puts some gas in his motorcycle. He says, what do I owe you? Yeah. Zizai has to be very quiet, Husky. He is a little bit of Batman. Yeah. What do I owe you? She says, 50 cents. Yeah. He's wearing his leather jacket. It's unzipped. Still no shirt. underneath. Amazing. And then she realizes who it is.
It's the cool rider. And they are going to go for this bike ride. I mean, Stephanie is living her best life. Yeah, they ride away on the bike. She's wearing no helmet. No helmet. Her hair also looks fine by the end of it. She hasn't eaten a bug.
Her eyes aren't watery. And her hair looks normal. You're right. Also, though, in the middle of them going down the road, she moves and straddles him from the front. Yeah, she does like a little leg wrap around. Yeah. They stop at sunset at the top of the hill.
They are kissing. He's never taken off his helmet or his goggles. Nope. This whole time. Pretty sure his goggles have fogged up. And he's about to reveal his identity. And then they're interrupted by the arrival of the entire T-Bird gang. Yeah.
And he races away. He says, I'll see you Friday, night at the talent show. And she's like, what talent show? How do you know? Yeah. Yeah. So this is pretty steamy this moment between them, right? Like they have some chemistry, like you're seeing them together. Would you be surprised to know that according to the internet, Michelle Pfeiffer and Maxwell Coughfield did not get along during filming? Oh, I read that it was platonic. I didn't know it was. Yeah, maybe it doesn't get along is the wrong wording. But a few years after the film was released, Maxwell said in an interview that they got along infamously. And Michelle Fiver
supposedly in an interview said that she found Maxwell self-adoring. So, you know, this just goes to show you. You don't have to have chemistry in real life to have sparks fly on screen. Acting! Acting! Well, here's the thing, guys. Johnny is super upset by Stephanie's new romance. He threatens to fight the mysterious writer. Stephanie's like, stay out of my life. Now, Paulette is pissed because she's like, Johnny, you don't ever get jealous about me. Everyone tells Sharon to shut up. So all the ladies leave in a huff.
They all storm inside the gas station. That's right. Slam the door. I have a wardrobe tidbit about this scene. Yes. First of all, I did not discuss this up top. I should have all the pink ladies have a look. Sharon is Jackie Kennedy.
That's why she wears the little pillbox hat and pearls. Stephanie is usually in all black. You know, she's the motorcycle kind of gal. She's got the necklace. Allison wears headbands and scarves. Paulette's character wants to be Marilyn Monroe. I mean, that's clear. Yes.
And in this scene, she is dressed almost identical to Marilyn in the white dress that even flies up as she walks into the gas station. But here's what actress Lorna Left had to say about trying to get this Marilyn look. The whole thing with me was they wanted this character to start. sort of be this character who was obsessed with Marilyn Monroe. So it was all about my hair. And Alan wanted me to be literally the platinum blonde. And he sent me to a hairdresser in Westwood. And she bleached out my hair. And I got to tell you, It was really painful.
And because in those days, they didn't have the real bleach now that they have that isn't painful. They bleached out my hair. I was weeping. And the next day, I went into hair and makeup for a hair and makeup test for the film. And the hairdresser went like this, and it came out in her hand. They had broken off all my hair. My hair was this long. And that's when Alan said, oh, put a wig on her.
I thought to myself, they couldn't have thought about that before they did that to me. So Alan that she's talking to is Alan Carr. He was a producer on the movie. And when you watch the interview, she sort of does the motion of what the hair person did. Yeah. It was just run her fingers through her hair. And it just came out in clumps. I mean, that's because, like she said, it was like, they just, like, scalded your hair.
Yeah. Back then. She said her hair ended up being like about an inch in length. It broke off that much. Wow. Yeah. Oh. So shout out to Lorna Left for enduring all that.
She's so good in the movie. She's so great. I love her as Paulette. I do too. Well, with all the girls inside the gas station, the T-Birds, they decide that they need some guaranteed action. Yeah, they're going to go prowling. Yeah.
They launch into. the go-and-prowling song, which kind of turns into a rehearsal for their talent show performance. Yeah, it like morphs into it. And I will say the number they perform, I guess, for the talent show, stylistically is really cool-looking. There's like this back, thin curtain on the stage. Yeah. And the gals, I guess where you go to score is the grocery store? Yeah, because it's like three ladies' shadows and their cats. Ash years at a grocery store and they're dancing. Yeah, it's this cool kind of black and white effect behind them.
Yeah. And now we know their talent show number. Right. All right. Well, now we're back in Miss Mason's class. She's now teaching English. Mm-hmm. And Stephanie has to stay after class because she didn't do well on her Shakespeare essay.
Right. Guess who's going to help her, you guys? It's Michael. Yeah. They have a very cute scene at like this little coffee shop. where he's going to help her with her homework. And there's chemistry there where he's just Michael. There is chemistry.
Yes, this scene is meant to show that Michael and Stephanie can have a connection even when he's not the cool writer. Right. But here's my beef with it. I don't understand how after spending a significant amount of time with Stephanie, Michael isn't totally turned off by her. She seems completely superficial and self-absorbed. She just keeps talking to him about the cool writer.
She says, what if he takes off his goggles? And he's just like an ordinary guy. And he's like, what if he is? And then she's like, I don't want to talk about this anymore. And then like she's obsessed with the ketchup. And like everything about her is like a giant turnoff to me. And she kind of eats a hamburger like the Carl's Jr. commercial.
I love how she eats the hamburger. What? It's so gross. No, I like it because she's not being fussy about it. She's going to dive right into that burger. and the fries, but I don't know. I mean, he's just like an intelligent person, and I feel like he's dumbing himself down for her, which always bums me out when people do in movies. I don't know. I think my thing with him is that he has to figure out how to be something he's not to win her over.
Yes. And that's what you don't want to do. You want to be your authentic self. Right. And have someone love you just as you are. Well, she is impressed by him. By his smarts. Yes. But then he downplays it. He's like, oh, I'm no smarter than you. I don't understand the stuff anymore than you do. I just know a few big words that impress teachers.
It's like, no, Michael, I think you understand it. I think you actually understand Hamlet. I think you do. Well, he's going to ask her out again. And she's like, no, you know, pink lady code, blah, blah, blah. And he's like, according to Dolores, the code stinks. Yeah. Johnny and Goose show up.
Johnny sees Michael talking to Stephanie. Once again, he's super ticked off. And lady, I think maybe Michael Scott had watched Greece too. Why? I think you've got to hear this. What do you want, Johnny? Yeah, well, I just want to let you know that I'm officially declaring us as an item officially over. You're declaring. That's correct.
Okay, fine. Okay? You declared it. It's over. Can I go now? He declared it. I declared bankruptcy. That's all I could think about in that scene.
Well, he asked her for her pink lady's jacket. Yeah. He's like, I have a rep to protect. If you're not going to date me, you're out of the pink ladies. If you're not going to date me while I date you and Paulette, you're out. Well, she doesn't give him his jacket. And do you see where she goes? Do you see where she walks to?
The pink lady car. Whose car is it? Now she's driving it. I know. Now she's getting in the car. I don't get it. It cuts to Michael who's standing watching all of this by his motorcycle, by the cool rider's motorcycle.
No one notices that he's standing next to the motorcycle with the red flames on it. What is with the vehicles in this film? Anyway. Oh, God. Now the part of the movie that I fast forward through. It's the super long. It's the only part. It's the only part I don't watch. Let me tell you why you shouldn't fast forward. Why? There is no one hotter in a turquoise sweater than Maxwell Caulfield.
He is so dreamy in this sweater. I swear to God, they're selling it right now at Marine Layer. It's like a timeless sweater. He looks so cute. The song is long and boring. It's called My Sharrade. Yeah. It's him in the cafeteria. It's all different like moments in high school where he's just tired of playing this charade. Half the time he's not singing. He's just walking and looking around. I know. And the song is like a voiceover? It's all odd. Yes. But now it's the night of the talent show. Stephanie's waiting out front in her sparkly jacket. Cool rider shows up. But uh-huh. But uh-oh, the T-birds show up too. So he rides away. Why? Why does he keep riding away from the T-birds? He took on 20 of the cycle lords outside the bowling alley.
four people. But apparently he can't take on these four guys on the motorcycle. So he speeds away and the T-birds chase him and then the girls follow them in the pink car. And guess what? There's a construction site. It conceals the deadly drop of dead man's curve. And he just goes flying off into the night. Can I say what I wrote? Yeah. He died? I thought where does the movie go from here? You really thought he died? How do you come back from that? I thought he'd. I died. Well, that's good. That's what they wanted you to think.
Stephanie's convinced, but I do have to go back because this is one of me and my sister's favorite lines from the movie. Oh, please, please. I'm sorry, say it. Say it. It's in the car when the pink ladies are chasing toward the construction site before he flies off the edge. And Sharon has a line because they're zipping around. And she goes. And Sharon is who you would be in the movie.
This is me. This is my line. She says, we're going to die. And I'm wearing my mother's underwear. Sharon's line. I bet you guys love that. We love that line. We would always say that line when it came up.
All right. So it's time for the talent show. I have this moment highlighted as my favorite Paulette moment because she finally lets Johnny have it. Yeah, Johnny thinks Paulette is dressed too skimpy. Johnny's not wrong. I'm sorry, for a high school student, is this what you wear, during the talent show. She's in...
Lausierre. Is it like a boostier unitard? It's a boostier. She's got on... What do you call those? What do you call that thing? You put around your leg that you throw a wedding.
A garter. I mean, she's covered, but it's very suggestive. Yeah. And I just want to... There's nothing wrong with it except that I think she's 17. I know what it looks like.
What? Visually for people who haven't seen the movie, if you made a Playboy Bunny outfit, but like into like more of a corset look. Yeah. Right? Mm-hmm. Okay.
It's like a one piece. Jordan's not a yet. Bating suit. Strapless. Mm-hmm. But lacy and suggestive. Yes. It's like what I wore in Blades of Glory.
Oh, yes, it is. That's exactly what it is. Now people are going to Google that lady. Well, do it. I look great. You looked great. I just have to say what Paulette says to him, though. Yeah, I love it.
She's like, maybe you can bully some chicks in this school, but this chick has been bully for the last time. I may not be the classiest chick, but I'm the best you're going to get. So take it or leave it. Yeah. And she's kind of swatting at him the whole time. Mm-hmm. He backs down.
I was like, way to go, Paulette. But first, we're going to see the T-Birds sabotage the Mr. Sandman trio. Yeah. They tie them up. And, like, turn the showers on them or something. Yes. And then the T-birds go out, and they do a great job. They're a big hit.
They crush it. They crush it. Everyone loves them. Yeah. Then we have the pink ladies number, the Girl for All Seasons. Yeah. Amazing costumes, by the way. There's so many costumes, you guys, because they do all the seasons.
I'm just going to highlight three. Okay. December is Stephanie in a Christmas tree-themed dress is pretty amazing. She is wearing a star on top of her head. Yes. And she looks like a Christmas tree. January, it's a champagne glass featuring foam legs sticking out of the top. Yeah.
combined with the red sparkly dress. It's amazing. February has to be in the top three. It's a wiggling George Washington face on a belly. She's a coin for President's Day in February. I did not. You know what? I thought she was Mount Rushmore. No, she's a coin. But what's interesting is that her body is painted to be the face of the coin. And the eyes of George Washington, are her boobs. And then she's like belly dancing, which makes his face move. And again, I just want to say, is this appropriate for high school? George Washington's eyes on a girl's boobs? I don't think it is.
I'm going to say no. I did not put those two together. I didn't realize his eyes were her boobs because I was so confused by why Mount Rushmore was being featured in February. Okay. Well, they go through all the seasons. When Stephanie comes out and she starts to sing, she... Hallucinates?
Yeah, she kind of zones out the star that's on top of her head. She takes it down into her hands and then it flies out of her hand. And then she, like, follows it to, like, la-la land. She's, like, in a dreamlike fantasy. Yes. And now we do have a sort of thing that I think is meant to represent heaven or something because Michael is now on top of a mountain of white motorcycles. I wrote, is he an angel?
This is what I wrote. Stephanie is now dressed as a Grecian goddess. Yep. She looks amazing. Yep. Michael's in all silver. This might be the weirdest number in the whole movie. There's a pile of old busted motorcycles that look white and dusty.
Are they like corpses? I don't know what they are. It's foggy. Oh, yeah, there's tons of fog. And I do have to note, again, that even in his silver motorcycle outfit, he has no shirt on under the jacket and zip down to his belly button. Yeah. This is a very long dream sequence song. It's a duet.
It's a duet. And Stephanie has two outfits. Yes. She's either Grecian goddess or she is also like in a silver jacket on the motorcycle with him. Yes. I wrote, don't know how you sing these weird. lyrics and not break, they are somehow 100% stone cold serious through this whole song, especially this part where there's a dialogue break.
And they talk to each other. Yeah, I have it. They do song talking. I have it. Oh, great. Here it is. Stephanie, please don't cry. It all seems so unfair.
Just when I found you, I lost you. That doesn't matter, no. The only thing that matters is that I love you. And you're the only one who can keep our love alive. So Stephanie, don't forget me. I promise. Yeah, so. Then it morphs back into her being in the talent show.
Yes, and she's singing this weird solo now that has nothing to do with calendar girls. She's singing, turn back, uh-oh, all by herself. The crowd is mesmerized. Yes. You could hear a pin drop. She's sad. She's on her knees. The song ends, and the audience erupts into a standing ovation.
Ovation. And then Johnny and Stephanie win the talent show. They win the talent show, which I didn't realize meant that they were crowned king and queen of a luau. Which is coming up. It's an all, I wrote at this point, what is happening? What is happening? Now we have a rockahoola luau. Yes, this is clearly the we go together of Greece, too.
This is, you know what this number is? We don't know where the script is going. Let's get everyone back in one big scene together. Dance it out. I wrote, there are so many continuity errors in this low-wile scene. I don't even know how to start. Well, I want to talk about how everybody is dressed so festively except for Stephanie, who's still mourning the death of Cool Rider, she shows up in a slouchy gray sweatshirt
and jeans. She's over it. She's not happy. She's done. But yeah, there's a big dance number. Big, big dance number. And then there's a big, like above ground swimming pool in the middle of this luau. My aunt Louise and Uncle Sonny had one.
I don't know how they put so many things in it. Well, it starts with Mr. Stewart and Miss Mason. They're in a boat in the middle. People are swimming and dancing in the water, but then suddenly they're not in the water. And you never see them again. In the water, out of the water. No one's drying off. There's no towels.
Yes. We dance until the sun sets. and now it's time for the king and queen to take their positions. They're in some kind of native dress. It doesn't feel appropriate. Yeah. They have crowns. They're in a bamboo raft with paddles.
Yes. And they're put in the above-ground pool. By, by, like, six high school guys who are dressed in loincloths. Yeah. Did you see the guy on the right? Is it the same guy that ran track? I don't know. I hope not because clearly they didn't heat this water.
Because when this guy hits the water, he visibly like flinches. Like you see like the wind come out of him. He's like, it's so cold. It's so cold. Johnny is smoking. He's always smoking. He drops his cigarette. He almost catches the raft on fire.
Yeah. The bamboo raft. He and Stephanie are bickering. She's in such a sour mood. and now wouldn't you know it? Wouldn't you know it? The cycle lord show up. Can we, there's one thing I've been wanting to say.
What is it? One thing. There's one thing. What is it? Just go with me on this. Let's say you're madly in love with a guy. Okay. Who plummets to his death off a, like a cliff on a motorcycle.
Yeah. And then you immediately go to your talent show. Yeah. What? That's why she couldn't get through the number, Anne. Why did she even go? go. I don't know. And now she's like on a pontoon boat and an above ground. That's why she's so grumpy. Okay. That's why she's so annoyed. Okay. Anyway, cycle lords show up.
Yes, and they're running over all the decorations. It's crazy. People, there's like a cake booth, and they're going to throw cakes at the cycle lords, but they end up throwing cakes at each other. Yeah. People are throwing stuffed animals at them. Stephanie and Johnny, they're trying to row the raft out of the pool, but they can't seem to row. It's not working. Don't worry. Don't worry. Because during the mayhem, the mysterious writer shows up.
He shows up. He is on top of a thatched roof. Very high. Yeah. Very high. He jumps off of it, legs split, and lands on what we guess is his motorcycle, because the next shot is him just riding away. How his nuts survive that.
I don't know. I don't know. Here's how he's going to save the day. He jumps over the pool of water. Jumps over, Stephanie. Yeah. And Johnny. Yeah.
He makes it all the way across. So that means that all the cycle lords have to do the same jump. But they can't do it and they all land in the water. But they don't land on Stephanie and Johnny. No. Because they're no longer in the pool. I guess they got out. Oh my gosh.
Lady, there's so much chatter online about it. People are like, okay, during the Luel, people appear to disappear and appear on the boat and appear and disappear and disappear. into the pool. Some people fall in, then they're not there. It's like a whole thing. Also, someone else pointed out, when the bike flips into the pool, the cord that they use to make the bike flip is completely visible. Oh. So there's that. I see. Well, I guess he did it. He saved the day. It's really nuts. The cycle lords could have ridden around the pool, but maybe not. I guess that's the challenge. That's how it works when you are cycle fighting. It's like, can you do the stunt or not?
Yeah. Stephanie's so excited. She's like, oh, my God, you're alive. She takes off her crazy outfit they had her wear, and under it is not her sweatshirt. Yeah, now she has a cute outfit on. A silver lamay, amazing shimmery dress slash Unitar. Michael, guys, now has a leather vest, collar up. No shirt, obvi. And at first, you guys, Johnny sees all of this, and he is so pissed off. And he runs. He's up to him. And then he's like, you got one more jump. And she's like, Johnny, hasn't there been enough? And then the T-birds are like, yeah, hasn't there been enough, Johnny? Hasn't there been enough?
And then he's like, jacket. And then he's like, Jacket. And then Paulette's like, jacket. And then he gets the jacket. And then he gives it to Michael. And he's made Michael a T-bird. And now he and Stephanie, they can be together. They can.
And there's going to be a lot of coupled them. The final song is called We'll Be Together. Everyone is dancing, and this song wins closest singing in each other's faces award. Yeah, there's a lot of spinning, singing into each other's faces. But I'm talking like maybe... Lip to lip. Like two fingers. Put two fingers up to your lips. Yep.
And then imagine someone else's face on the other side of your finger. Singing at you. Singing, full voice. I have an audio clip. It has a little bit of dialogue between. Stephanie and Michael, and then it leads into the top of this song. I never thought you'd kiss me like that if you knew what I really was. Are you crazy?
I'm a two for the price of one. You certain? I've never been certainer. No, son. The certainest. The certainest. Yeah, I like that. I'd love to kiss you again.
Yeah. I would have suggested. that they cut that dialogue before the singing? Because again, Michael, what are you seeing in her? This is the woman for you? Lady, I love this movie so much now, and I am the certainest of it. I hear you. I hear you. You know what? He accepts her where she is. That's right. That's the love. He's like, I love you. You dumb, dumb. Did I please kiss you again?
Maybe he's like, don't speak. Don't speak. Could we go back to the kissing? I love you so much when we're kissing. And she's like, you don't need to talk to me. Just let me ride on your motorcycle. Maybe this is a relationship in silence. Well, this whole thing is going to morph into graduation.
Now we're back outside Rideau High. Everyone's in caps and gowns in front of the school. They're throwing their caps in the air. Everyone's singing toward the camera, except for Stephanie and Michael, who are still singing right into each other's faces. And then we're going to have this final montage that I've always loved. It starts with the whole group of people running toward the camera. They jump in the air and it's like a freeze frame.
And that sort of like becomes like a yearbook picture. Yeah. And then you see everybody kind of coupled up in their couple pairs and they run toward the camera kind of in slow motion and they do some sort of fun jump and it freezes. And that's part of the yearbook. Yes. There were two alternate endings for this movie. Would you like to hear them? I can't wait. Okay. So one alternate ending had Michael and Stephanie flying off into the sky on a motorcycle, which would have mirrored Danny and Sandy flying off in the car at the end of Greece. They didn't do that.
But also, Patricia Birch proposed an idea to feature John Travolta and Olivia Newton-John reprising their characters as a now-married couple running a gas station at the end of the movie, and it would have even involved John Travolta singing a new number called Gas Pump Jockey. But this did not come to fruition. So I guess there was the option to end the movie with a little cameo. So I guess they would have ridden their motorcycle together. to Danny and Sandy's gas station. Yeah.
And there would have been this little reunion. I guess with a whole song. How does gas pump jockey go? I don't know. Speaking of songs, so you watched this movie for the first time. Last week. Yes. Aren't the songs so catchy?
You know these songs are good because you hear them once and you can sing, I want to score tonight. You can sing, let's do it for our country. You know these songs after one time watching the movie. Driving in here today, I was singing, I'm going to go tonight. Exactly. It's great.
Yeah. That's a great musical. That is a really fun musical. And really, Greece, too, has everything. It's got Russia. It's got fallout shelters. It's got lots of cigarettes, lots of gum, gum, and stiff, collared shirts. Yeah. You guys, I highly recommend it. And I also want to say thank you today.
In the booth, we have Jordan filling in for Sam. Thank you, Jordan. You're welcome. I was so excited to be helping with this episode because I grew up avidly watching Greece, too. How many times have you seen it? Oh, many times. I had a vinyl of it growing up because my parents, they graduated in 72. I literally, my dad rode a motorcycle and worked on them his entire life. I have pictures of him doing wheelies and next to, like, motorcycles. Your dad was a cool writer, Jordan. He was a Thunderbird. He was a Thunderbird.
And Matt is here all the way from San Francisco. Matt, thanks for being here today. This was great. This was very fun to watch. My sister and I are Greece purists, so we never really delved into this. So this was interesting to watch. I had a good time. Well, I want to say a thank you to Nathan for suggesting this movie.
Mm-hmm. Hit us up, guys. Let us know what do you want us to watch because we like watching stuff together. We really do. I couldn't have predicted half of the plot lines for Greece 2. It was a real adventure. And I hope you guys all score tonight, whatever that means to you. We love you and we'll see you next week.
Delight, I love doing it. Me too. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.